les étals et les commerces de madina le
plus grand marché de la guinée ne
manquent pas encore de marchandises
le problème c'est que les entrepôts
déborde de prévalence de cette maladie
des activités sont paralysées la
fermeture en nous des frontières du
sénégal et de la côte d'ivoire a fait
dégringoler les chiffres d'affaires
record de stocks avant la crise de
l'ebola cet exportateur de produits
agricoles vendée dix mille sacs de
farine par mois maintenant ils peinent à
en vendre 1000 par mois
si cela continue pendant quelques mois
ce corps humain par total pour les
opérateurs et pour tous ceux qui vivent
de l'agriculture c'est à dire 10
millions de guinéens sont aussi frappés
de plein fouet parce que les fruits et
les légumes qui ne sont pas vendus
localement dans les marchés pourrissent
dans les chambres ou ce qu'ils ont
produit ce presque gâter parce qu'un
jeune aura eu pour but pour exporter la
production de café a chuté de 50 % celle
de l'huile de palme de 75% dans les
hôtels le taux d'occupation est passé de
80 à moins de 40%
beaucoup d'entreprises sur la place
souffre beaucoup parce qu'il n'ya pas
des changes
un pays ne peut pas vivre sans échange
fait mais chaloupe dirige une agence de
voyages qui embauche une dizaine de
personnes des employés qui depuis deux
mois on fait plus d'annulations que de
réservation on est comme une famille ici
on
on est là depuis très longtemps je
connais même les enfants de certaines de
mes employés et donc aujourd'hui je peux
pas leur dire bon avec les problèmes
financiers non j'essaie de tenir le
court jusqu'en octobre les mines du pays
étaient peu affectés par les mollahs la
plupart exploitant des minerais dans des
régions épargnées par le virus
cela a changé quand des entreprises
étrangères ont rapatrié leurs employés
expatriés
ce petit exploitant d'or a cessé ses
activités il y a quelques semaines avec
la maladie et bola c'est pas évident les
gens fuient des mines exploitées plus là
bas vous rentrez arrêter la vente d'eau
de l'or est ce que ça continue
pour le moment non ça c'est arrêté
seulement les clandestins travail
il ya un impact relativement assez
important dans sur les activités rio
tinto est une des plus importantes mines
hier en guinée en octobre elle a incité
ses employés non guinée à partir en
disant que les assurances et les
gouvernements ne pouvait assurer leur
évacuation médicale 75% des expatriés de
rio tinto ont quitté le pays
un départ volontaire notre
responsabilité c'est d'expliquer à nos
travailleurs l'envergure et la gravité
de la situation
ensuite les options qu'on leur offre à
la gare dans ses options ils peuvent à
la fois ou décider dans ces conditions
seul accompagné qui renforce les mesures
de prévention de protection de ces
travailleurs et deuxième chose librement
qu'ils peuvent consentir à un départ rio
tinto a ralenti le développement de
gisements faire dans une région touchée
par les mollahs mais l'exploitation de
bauxite n'est pas encore affecté trois
bateaux par semaine quitte la guinée à
destination du québec pour éviter la
propagation
les équipages des navires n'ont aucun
contact avec les travailleurs qui font
le chargement ici sophie langlois
radio-canada à conakry maintenant vous
savez les pays touchés par les mollahs
sont parmi les plus pauvres du monde
voyons quelques chiffres à l'appui en
guinée dans ce fils viennent nous parler
le pib par habitant dépasse à peine les
500 $ par année c'est encore pire au
liberia est à peine mieux en sierra
leone
par comparaison la moyenne mondiale est
d'environ dix mille 500 $ par personne
et au canada il frôle les 50 de 1000 $
c'est environ 100 fois plus donc que les
pays affectés